Let's take a look at the kind of tags
that can be handled in Tag Manager.
Click on Tags > New.
You can use Tag Manager to send events
from your app to Google Analytics,
to Google AdWords, and to doubleclick.
You can also have events by
Function Calls and Custom Image Tags.
And we're going to be focusing on
sending events to Google Analytics.
When you want to send data from your app
to Analytics, you can send your tracking
data to Tag Manager instead
of directly to Analytics.
Tag Manager will forward
the tracking data to Analytics.
The end result will be the same as
if we'd send it direct to Analytics.
The tracking data shows up in Analytics.
But now, if you want to make changes
to the way the data appears in
the Analytics dashboard,
you can implement these changes through
the Tag Manager dashboard instead of
having to code the changes in the app.
While you're testing your app on your
device, right there connected to your
computer, it seems simple enough to
compile the changes, and re-deploy.
But once your app's in production,
and available on the Play store,
it's easier to change the description
of the data that's collected,
using the Tag Manager UI.